let's talk about fighting games
back in the 90s fighting games were huge
from Street Fighter to Mortal Kombat and
Virtual Fighter to Tekken this genre was
crushing it and growing up in that era I
was a part of that but I noticed that
fighting games kind of fell off as our
case died in the late 90s and early
2000s games were still releasing
especially in their 3D space but 2D
Fighters especially were bleeding but
after Street Fighter 4 everything would
change so let's talk about how Street
Fighter 4 revitalized fighting games
[Music]
while I love fighting games growing up
I'm honestly not an expert so after
doing plenty of research online I
decided to sit down and talk with an
actual expert Maximilian dude that makes
the end for doing this by the way yeah
no problem I saw the the Twilight
Princess video and I thought it was
really fascinating and I was like yeah
that's pretty much what I remember when
that game came out but before diving
into Street Fighter 4 I think we need
some historical context while fighting
games had definitely existed notably
1980s boxing on Atari 2600 and 1984's
karate champ which was Data east's
best-selling arcade game of all time the
genre didn't really pop off until Street
Fighter 2 hit the scene
foreign
1991 Street Fighter 2 absolutely blew
every fighting game until then out of
the water with it giving players
accurate control interesting characters
unique Combos and skills for each of
them and absolutely fantastic music that
I will never get sick of while fighting
games were walking Street Fighter made
them run suddenly people were showing up
at arcades just to Duke it out in Street
Fighter 2. a tournament scene formed
around the game as well as future
Fighters people wanted to prove they
were the best Street Fighter 2 did so
well it's estimated to have earned over
10 billion dollars and is considered one
of the most financially successful games
of all time there was a cartoon spin-off
based on the characters as well as an
anime and god-awful live-action film
more importantly though it also inspired
an entire genre fatal Fury Mortal Kombat
King of Fighters Primal Rage Samurai
Showdown Eternal Champions Killer
Instinct and so many any more fighting
games were a direct result of the
success of Street Fighter 2. 2 2D
fighting games were on fire but then
[Applause]
Virtual Fighter sorry I only own Virtual
Fighter 2 and Virtual Fighter kids and I
actually prefer kids so uh that's the
prop while some games had attempted to
create 3D Fighters prior to Virtual
Fighter it was this 1993 game that would
introduce another dimension literally
into fighting games at the time 2D games
were still prospering I mean this was
only two years after Street Fighter 2
but it did start a growing Trend many
new fighting games especially in arcades
were opting to be the most Cutting Edge
with 3D graphics and a new style of play
we saw games like Tekken Dead or Alive a
personal favorite of mine rival schools
and soul Edge start to take off even
Mortal Kombat had picked up on the 3D
Trend releasing Mortal Kombat 4 in 1997
which went full on 3D Tekken was flying
high and then Soul Calibur a sequel to
Soul Edge was universally revered 3D is
a huge part of the evolution of the
industry in the 90s and Capcom you know
holding onto their Laurels with a
Viceroy fist was like we're not letting
go of this 2D thing so their cps3 boards
that were powering Street Fighter were
like super dedicated animation 2D
engines so Street Fighter at this point
is not changing and they have some ex
games that don't look great in
comparison so the franchise is still
sort of stuck in this 2D Revolution 3D
was the thing fighting games were now
striving for but at the same time Capcom
was finally working on a follow-up to
Street Fighter 2 that would release in
1997. Street Fighter 3. however the
spice Street Fighter 2's incredible
Success Street Fighter 3 [__] bombed
nobody played it it almost got as much
play time in the majority of arcades I
went to then Street Fighter the movie
the game the only reason this was
happening is because Capcom had burned a
lot of bridges with so many different
iterations of Street Fighter 2. many of
these machines would kind of go unplayed
because people just were buying so many
copies of Street Fighter so yeah there
was an appropriate decline around the
Street Fighter 3 era or even other
Capcom fighting games like the versus
series were starting to do really well
Street Fighter wasn't in a great spot at
this point that is not to say Street
Fighter 3 was bad in fact it's now super
beloved especially third strike but at
the time there were issues after a long
and troubled development cycle which
involved junior members who had never
worked on a fighting game working on
Street Fighter 3 eventually shinichiro
obata stepped up to the plate as planner
and put a proper overall design in place
I'm not going to go over this too much
but polygon has an excellent oral
history on the subject long story short
it didn't have established characters as
it was originally planned to be a new IP
and Ryu and Ken were only added later
after it was decided the game would be
Street Fighter 3 but these designs
weren't popular and even shinichiro
obada wasn't a fan stating the problem
was that the characters had very
uninspired designs and I would say they
were quite strange in comparison and as
it turns out myself as little Dave
wasn't a fan of this changeup and
neither were many other Street Fighter
fans I'm a bigger for you main that's
always been my character so I was at
least happy he was there but I was like
man like all all the characters I love
aren't here so the term that was kind of
passed around back in the day was this
game's got a bunch of weirdos in it they
took characters that were kind of known
and then hyper combined them dolls them
and Blanca get turned into like necro
people just didn't know how to take it
they already did it before in Street
Fighter Alpha where they switched around
a lot of the roster but that was a lot
more accepted I feel according to Akira
yasua an artist on Street Fighter 3 the
initial version of Street Fighter 3 saw
shockingly low sales I remember seeing
the numbers and just being really
surprised at how the game just wasn't
selling it felt like we created the
worst selling game at Capcom it felt
awful shinichiro obada goes on to point
out that they barely broke even and were
lucky not to have gone into the red
there was also another issue at play
here laid out by Bill Gardner then CEO
and president of Capcom USA when I first
joined the company coinop was so much
bigger than consumer just a number of
times bigger that was the Mainstay of
the Capcom business was coinop so Street
Fighter 3 came out the Home console
business was starting to really take off
these are a number of fighting games I
own I own them I don't have to go to an
arcade to play them as the 90s went on
and we reached the odds video game
console Hardware was catching up with
the power of arcades part of the reason
players went to play Arcade games was
for experiences consoles weren't
powerful enough to play but by the late
90s the PS1 Sega Saturn and N64 could
pretty well handle most games coming to
arcades and by 2000 and the release of
the PS2 this was only further cemented
there's also the fact that by then most
Gamers or their friends owned some
console so you didn't need to spend
money renting time with the game when
you could just buy it and play it as
much as you wanted or at least you know
rent it from Blockbuster where you could
play it as many times as you wanted
during that rental period without
wasting quarters so capcom's coin out
business was dying and that brings us
neatly back to SNK and King of Fighters
whose business model was also based
around coinop they were one of cap com's
largest competitors in the 2D fighting
game space with fatal Fury art of
fighting Samurai Showdown and King of
Fighters being particularly well known
yeah they went bankrupt it wasn't just
Capcom that was that was feeling the
financial impact of 2D fighting games
not doing super great it was also their
biggest competitor slash cohort in the
industry which was SNK and yeah a lot of
the money was escaping the industry at
this point so licenses to games like
King of Fighters were sold off and the
results of the games while annual were
generally viewed as not very good the 3D
ERA King of Fighters games are are very
weird some of them are missing the mark
with some of its fan base and not
exactly what they're looking for in the
early 2000s fighting games were still
seeing some life and some big releases
in particular in 2000 you had Guilty
Gear X 2000 also saw versus games like
Marvel vs Capcom 2 which was massive and
Capcom versus SNK but what was truly
Making a Splash were those 3D Fighters
Virtual Fighter Dead or Alive Tekken and
Soul Calibur has some big early odds
releases and Mortal Kombat was
um kind of going through a phase where
they were trying things and then there
was this little game released in 1999
Smash Brothers was big also different in
fact so different many people held this
sentiment and still hold the sentiment
that smash isn't a true fighting game
either way it wasn't a traditional 2D
fighting game by any means now before I
move on I absolutely need to clarify
something I'm not trying to claim 2D
fighting games or the fighting game
genre was completely dead that's not the
case here but it wasn't thriving like it
was in the 90s to me it felt like that
self-fulfilling prophecy you see
happened to morning genres kind of like
what happened with survival horror
because sales are down companies don't
want to invest a lot of money into a new
major title and because the games that
do come out don't get the proper budget
or resources those games don't do well
rinse and repeat and the thing about
fighting games is they thrive on
competition Smash Brothers was a unique
case because unlike other fighting games
four players could play at once making
it more of a party game with a hardcore
scene emerging from that but with
traditional fighting games a lot of them
were struggling to find ways to reach a
console market and were therefore
investing in major single player
campaigns like Mortal Kombat introducing
a single player campaign Conquest mode
on the 2D front even arxus whose Guilty
Gear had a cult following was
experimenting with 3D with Guilty Gear 2
Overture they did still put out
occasional 2D Fighters like Guilty Gear
xx and battle Fantasia which is on a 2d
plane but sales weren't exactly
fantastic for either meanwhile SNK was
pumping out King of Fighters games and
while they certainly had their fans to
be sure they were failing to make a
major Splash in the overall fighting
game community and weren't really
revitalizing it from the peak of the
early 90s meanwhile Capcom would been
one of the kings of fighting games had
remained relatively quiet after the
release of Street Fighter EX3 in 2000
the sentiment around Capcom was that a
new numeric Street Fighter would never
be made as the demand just wasn't there
for everything that we understood uh
Capcom was effectively done with their
fighting games we can think fighting Jam
or Capcom fighting Evolution for that
because it was not good all of this led
to what's considered the fgc or fighting
game Community Dark Age yeah the fgc
Dark Age term is funny with perspective
now but was real and yeah once again the
fgc is largely fighting game Capcom
focused so for for them it was a Dark
Age after cvs2 which was the last big
game Capcom fighting get jammed did not
hit in the ways that people wanted uh it
wouldn't be until like HD Remix would
come out and even that a lot of people
are not very happy with just in general
but there was a larger like several year
time frame in the mid 2000s and later in
the 2000s before sf4 where this is
considered the dark ages of fighting
games but mind you like bruh Tekken 5
came out in this time frame the Guilty
Gear XX series continues to expand and
get a whole bunch of different versions
Soul Calibur has like three different
games that come out it's a dark age for
for Capcom fans it's a Dark Age board
Street Fighter and Marvel vs Capcom and
darkstalkers but with perspective it
wasn't exactly a dark age for the entire
genre as a whole but something was
hanging the 2000
Revitalize the genre online play and a
wave of new consoles multiplayer online
definitely existed but it was typically
relegated to PC whereas most fighting
games were on consoles additionally with
fighting games lag is a far bigger issue
fighting games are reliant on players
fast twitch responses if there's any lag
online then your input will be delayed
or you'll receive a delay in the input
from your opponent it's still an issue
with online gaming today but it is
significantly better at the same time
while the PS2 and original Xbox kinda
had online services with Xbox Live
launching in 2002 and the PS2 had a
network adapter most games didn't
utilize these and they didn't have
widespread player adoption but the Xbox
360 and PS3 had far better internet
support and the internet in general was
getting faster and more usage and Xbox
especially honed in on this with their
XBox Live service making digital
downloads a major Marketplace that
they'd have fully promote in 2006 Capcom
decided to re-release Street Fighter 2
hyper fighting the Xbox Live's Online
Marketplace this might seem somewhat
unnotable except for one thing Capcom
had worked on the netcode for hyper
fighting to give the game online play
and it was popular it didn't blow
people's minds and it wasn't the first
time you could play fighting games
online but it worked and it worked well
at least for the time before sf4 there's
there's a couple of errant notes of
Street Fighter like being around we get
this cheese ball port on the Xbox 360
called Street Fighter 2 hyper fighting
and yeah it's a it's a port of Street
Fighter 2 turbo slash hyperfighting that
was from the arcades and it has online
play on the Xbox 360 and that's pretty
much the only I remember being so
excited about this because it was the
only Street Fighter thing we heard of
for years and it was like oh my God
Street Fighter isn't completely dead I
guess suddenly online multiplayer seem
like a real possibility for fighting
games suddenly after the death of
arcades fighting games might be able to
bring back competition in fact Street
Fighter 2 hyper fighting had been so
successful for Capcom that it brought
back the man for a new Street Fighter so
in 2006 producer yoshinoriono pitched
three Fighter 4 and r d had kg unifune
approved the project it was decided to
make Street Fighter 4 2.5 D all the
characters and background elements would
be 3D but the fighting itself would take
place on a 2d plane just like
traditional Street Fighter it was art
director and character designer Daigo
ikeno who would pitch and use a
non-photorealistic rendering style to
give the characters a hand-drawn look
with plenty of stylistic flair for
Street Fighter 4 yoshinoriona wanted to
keep the game closer to Street Fighter 2
compared to other games in the franchise
which helped bring the game back to an
accessible level which meant a lot of
changes from the less popular Street
Fighter 3. it also meant that people who
grew up on Street Fighter 2 but hadn't
played fighting games in a long time
would feel right at home with this one
however although it felt like sf2 it
still maintained some elements from
Street Fighter 2's successors
additionally Street Fighter 4 added
Focus attacks which allowed players to
essentially Parry encounter attack on
top of that there were brand new ultra
combos which were devastating cinematic
attacks players could perform if the
Revenge meter filled up enough by taking
damage from their opponent and while
Street Fighter 4 did of course release
the arcades notably the game included
online play right out of the gate for
console and PC players which I'll get
right back to but first the thing about
Street Fighter 4 is it was fantastic the
game was critically acclaimed with a 94
out of 100 for PS3 at Metacritic and 93
out of 100 for Xbox 360. the game sold
incredibly well at 3.4 million copies
and in general fans loved it Street
Fighter was back so great Street
Fighter's back but what makes four so
special well for one thing the last time
there was a brand new numeric entry into
the street fighter series was 1997 with
Street Fighter 3. that means it had been
over 10 years since the street fighter
had gotten that special brand new
numeric and wasn't a spin-off by being
so stingy to give a new Street Fighter
game that number and not like alpha or
ex it automatically helped Capcom create
a huge amount of hype for a brand new
numeric entry meanwhile the game
actually received genuine marketing
support from Capcom yeah the marketing
push for Street Fighter 4 was big and
the idea behind Street Fighter's
marketing was that we're going back to
the start right we're going to bring you
back to Street Fighter 2 because that is
what you know and love we're gonna bring
it back to its roots so they had a good
plan right and that plan was effective
and it worked they were catering towards
Nostalgia and the relative newness of a
new Street Fighter and its systems and
visuals we heard a lot about it and they
put a lot of money into it and that's
probably a big reason why it was so
successful the marketing team focused on
making sure that players understood the
game felt like Street Fighter 2. Capcom
worked to Hype the release of Street
Fighter 4 and it worked big time the few
arcades that did guess repair for
headlines around the block for people to
compete and play the hype around this
game is ballistic right once again the
the core centrifuge of what is known as
the fighting game Community was very
Capcom focused and we were just prepared
and it was dead right it was put in to
the ground there was a gravestone made
it was relatively buried so any of us
that were getting anything it was
relatively exciting but not what we
wanted to eventually get to the point
where oh no it's coming back and it's
coming back in a big way
I don't think I've ever been more hyped
for a game in my entire life to me the
only other thing that Rivals the amount
of excitement for Street Fighter 4's
eventual launch is like a Modern Warfare
2 situation and I don't mean current day
Modern Warfare 2 I mean like Xbox 360
era that was crazy best example of this
is I I got lucky to be in the epicenter
of Street Fighter 4 when the arcade
release happened and several arcades in
my area of Southern California got
Street Fighter 4 Japanese arcade boards
these things are like fifteen to twenty
thousand dollars a piece in 2008 so
places like super arcade and Family Fun
Arcade and arcade Infinity become this
ridiculous mecca for Street Fighter 4
content these arcades that were not
designed to have this many people in
them had that many people crammed around
the Street Fighter 4 cabinets that there
would be a list where dude be like hey I
want to play the game what do I got to
do and there'd be like a producer he's
like okay so what's your name and he
would pull out a list man and there'd be
pages long of just names and this guy
would be like the one making sure that
everyone gets their time on the machine
in some way I don't feel like any other
fighting game launch
um after Street Fighter 4 has matched
that absolute hype and excitement it was
the proper Reckoning of a franchise that
everyone was not ready to come back and
when it came back in such a way uh the
world showed up
that was how we all felt that was a
perfect representation of the energy in
the community around this time for the
collector's edition they included a
65-minute animated film Street Fighter
for the ties That Bind madcats made
various controllers for the game and
meanwhile there was of course the push
across gaming magazines and then there's
that whole online play thing online
playing fighting games had just started
to be implemented with games like Tech
and dark res Resurrection Street Fighter
2 hyper fighting and Virtua Fighter 5.
Tekken 6 had come out even before Street
Fighter 4 did and I being relatively
excited to get back in Tekken since
Tekken 5 was ready to jump online and
nurse learn some new characters and you
know hope that the online is going to
perform better than Tekken 5 dark
Resurrection on PS3 which was a trash
fire in terms of online play
to learn that it wasn't that much
different and it felt about the same and
I think I after two days I was just done
but Street Fighter 4's netplay was
actually good it had functional
matchmaking it didn't go down or have
really big problems in between its
launch period and a lot of people still
play competitive Street Fighter 4 to
this day I mean online they won't play
people that are far away but they'll
play people in close proximity because
for delay based netcode
um if you play people that are up close
and it is functioning well it will work
and it will it will perform with a not
too much input delay to compromise The
Experience so lucky enough Street
Fighter 4 is a game that kind of nails
all of those those situations and it's
got cool Championship modes it's got
like tournament modes that you can play
online it is the best and highest effort
fighting game online systems that I
think had been done so they knew they
knew that people weren't going to be
playing this in person that much anymore
much less the arcade scene is going to
be playing the arcade version for
forever there is already a an element at
Capcom where they were sort of aware
that this is where the industry is going
and they have to go in sort of full stop
but is it the best netcode ever with
Harrison now it's not it's still it's
pretty rough but at the time when your
perspective is very few games that even
run online it was almost the best there
was thanks to Street Fighter 4's
extremely strong sales it brought the
thundered online play The Game's use of
online plays skyrocketed the competitive
scene as players could finally have that
arcade experience again a little before
in 2007 a little site called Justin TV
had started this was a live streaming
site and it's game streaming which had
become the most popular part would
eventually become Twitch TV meaning that
suddenly players could start streaming
themselves playing fighting games online
there's also the rise of YouTube which
has started in 2005 and was now really
starting to pick up even as somebody
like me that had a very focused amount
of tournament experience with Street
Fighter 4 was able to go on and at least
share those experiences with people and
let them know that you can get better at
this that there is a way and before it
felt like the gap between a a casual
player and people that were hardcore
tournament slash arcade folks that went
there religiously was so big and now
that does seem to be shrinking in a lot
of ways the scene is expanding but the
access of information was so much more
than any other game it allowed Street
Fighter 4 to thrive and grow Tech and
make things that were sometimes
impossible even easier because the
content creation age had started so like
you were saying perfect place right
scenario right time once again this only
further helped to promote Street Fighter
4 as players were actively streaming
themselves competing with other people
and bringing about even more awareness
and interest to the genre as a whole
remember that number of 3 million sales
well what that translates to is people
suddenly joining the fighting game
Community people were competing online
and streaming Street Fighter 4. suddenly
the game had become a catalyst for the
fighting game Community thanks to Street
Fighter 4 sales it also proved that
fighting games could sell incredibly
well on under the right circumstances
Street Fighter 4 was definitely
responsible for I'd say because of how
much money it made and how successful it
was putting like the glimmer in the eye
of other developers that know our
fighting game can do it right uh we're
not we're not going to be as big a
street fighter but the chance of them
evolving in some way and taking their
franchise to a different level whether
that was like Mortal Kombat or you know
Guilty Gear XR later on with a very
similar 2.5 D styling I think is that's
unprecedented Street Fighter 4 was the
reason that kind of happened and it is
one of the bigger reasons why fighting
games from this point forward sort of
are given a launch pad to have the
opportunity to even do so and the great
thing was this
fighting game fans in in general if any
of these three million players enjoyed
Street Fighter 4 there's a very real
possibility they'd be introduced to
other 2D Fighters like Guilty Gear or
hey that other 2008 arcsis release blaze
blue in the fighting game Community
taking a look at Evo Street Fighter 4
brought a giant new momentum to the
annual fighting game tournament that
started in 1996. in 2009 when Evo added
Street Fighter 4 to the roster
organizers had never seen such a large
turnout before there were 1040 entrants
with Street Fighter Force tournament
having three times more entrance than
any other game Evo as a whole is thought
to have a pretty Street Fighter 4 era
and Post Street Fighter 4 era as that's
just how much popularity to help bring
to the competitive fighting scene it
marked the start of substantial growth
and interest according to Ed Boone
co-creator of Mortal Kombat while Street
Fighter 4 didn't Inspire Mortal Kombat 9
which brought the series back to its 2D
roots and also performed incredibly well
for the team Street Fighter 4 proved to
them that they were on the right track
of bringing Mortal Kombat back to 2D and
it helped energize them which I found
particularly interesting as Mortal
Kombat 9 released in 2011 three years
after Street Fighter IV so I wanted to
get Max's thoughts on it the question
I've kind of been pondering in my head
if Street Fighter 4 hadn't happened if
that hadn't come out and Mortal Kombat 9
came out exactly as is do you think it
would have had that same sort of effect
on the community for sure
um and and that's a it's an interesting
take because MK9 actually did have a
huge impact on the community it just
didn't have an impact on what became the
proper known term fgc if you're in the
fgc you're pretty much into like Street
Fighter or Marvel right and then there
was these segregated sort of separate
fgcs of like Tekken players and Anime
players and Mortal Kombat interesting
they almost get different names but if
we're talking about impact and scale uh
in terms of how things would be changing
and moving forward MK K9 took seemingly
like a lot of notes from Street Fighter
4 came out also like three years after
sf4 did and I'm sure like some of the
things they did in sf4 manipulated and
changed what they were eventually doing
in MK9 in some way even if they were
planning on going back to 2D but it
clearly is like inspired in a lot of
ways because it does the same roster
choices it does the same sort of visual
choices and MK9 is largely the reason
NRS is in the spot they're at right now
where they're the absolute Top Dog King
because Street Fighter has faltered
several times from you know sf4 and
Beyond and Capcom fighting games in
general have as well but netherrealm has
consistently improved and engaged and
enhanced every single title from Mortal
Kombat 9 and Beyond and regardless of
what you feel about gameplay those games
are substantial updates from the
previous one and our big new experiences
that are worth buying and put your money
into at some point I do think to
fighting games we're going to make a
comeback but there's absolutely no
denying the insane impact Street Fighter
4 had in revitalizing both 2D fighting
games and the entire fighting game
Community as a whole it was definitely
the right game at the right time thanks
to it being a fantastic fighting game
being a new Miracle entry into one of
the most popular fighting game
franchises of all time receiving
marketing support and having online play
it brought all new players into fighting
games and helped bring about a whole new
wave of 2D Fighters
Street Fighter 4 is an astronomical game
not just for Street Fighter but for
fighting games as a whole because a lot
of different approaches and tacked from
other companies change after sf4 and
that is how Street Fighter 4's saved 2D
fighting games I hope you guys enjoyed
we have a whole playlist of games that
save their respective system franchise
or genres so please consider checking
those out a huge huge thank you to
Maximilian dude for coming on this
episode talking to him was an absolute
blast he makes amazing content so if you
somehow haven't seen it please check it
out one more thing the Street Fighter 2
intro music is still my favorite song in
the entire franchise so please make more
remixes of it please I am begging you
thank you